good morning Millennials and welcome
back to the toast happy Tuesday hope
everyone's having a blessed and sacred
day speaking of blessed and sacred
I have nothing to say no kidding I'm
joined in Studio by The Statler Margo is
here filling in for Jax today so we
could be in studio looking gorgeous in
our white coolock in our right cool and
I are we really like have like the same
outfit but just different we're both
doing like Coastal you know they're
calling it now Coastal granddaughter
young Coastal grandmother okay I'm in
and we're both wearing our Sphinx pants
you can use code Claudia expense no you
can use clone Margo xbangs no I think
you know I really think I think you can
use a lot of eggs
hi how you doing good I can't when you
just said it was Tuesday like you ruined
my day some of the most devastating news
I've heard all it definitely should be
Wednesday by now it should be Friday
okay yes no like that's pushing it as
long as we're asking it should be
Saturday no because then you're close to
Monday Friday I'm good with be still to
work on Friday that's one of my last day
baby summer Friday yeah well we're
recording of course with the counselor
so early in the morning which I'm sure
all the girls will appreciate yeah
people comment they're like whenever
Margo comes on it always comes over
early because I tried to do it before
we're for work so I'm happy for everyone
but not for me I woke up literally the
crack of dawn to look as ugly as I do
the weather I it's like it's it's not
it's gotten to it's gotten to the point
it's no longer hair weather
yeah I realized it yesterday because I
walked to work and normally like I'm
fine and I walked work yesterday I
showed up dripping sweat like wet hair
not okay and I was like oh we're here
we're here it's so annoying it's like
now is the time of year where you spend
so much time on your hair and you walk
out and it's useless that's why maybe
you just we both look like kind of
frizzy today wait what do you mean I I
straightened my hair I was gonna say
maybe that's why you go into your
straight hair era oh you think
summertime is straight hair era maybe
because if you're sweating then just
it's the same you know it like Pats down
to your head I guess I like I'm so over
my like looking wearing straight hair on
my head you know no I understand I'm
back in that but however I'm really just
a bun girl yeah no I was actually
thinking today's like really kind of hot
I might actually you're literally
wearing a cashmere sweater yeah I am
wearing a cable knit that's a really
good call
um
yeah no I have no rebuttal to that it's
just that like in the summer everywhere
I go was air conditioned so I end up
being so cold when I wear shorts yeah
but I guess this chunky knit was not I'm
not in my shorts era that's for damn
sure like to just be walking around the
city in shorts like is really tough for
me like if I'm going somewhere
Absolutely I'll be in shorts like
wearing shorts to work like wearing
shorts in general like it just feels
fraudulent and like I have to shave my
legs and I don't want to do that I am
far too old to be wearing shorts like
it's just shorts and me like we no
longer see each other yeah you know a
skirt I could do a skirt is cute but I
loved winter when we could wear skirts
in time my favorite legs or tan them so
it's before we dive into the Fast Five
um what's new with you oh um nothing
yeah and now just one week closer to my
Yellowstone trip that I'm excited for oh
happy for you
um I actually did we had a conversation
last week about like me last minute
joining the trip but I think I've
decided like yeah I figured yeah yeah
it's just I really do want to go to
Yellowstone but in your own way in my
own way for sure and then I feel like
you would go and you'd be like maybe Miz
in the tent and then you'd like have
this weird like bad taste in your mouth
about Yellowstone but it's not
Yellowstone it would be you sleeping in
a tent no and if I went and I wasn't
like enjoying the accommodations like I
would ruin the trip for everyone oh my
God if I'm complaining the whole time a
hundred percent yeah because like
complaining is my love language but I do
know how destructive it can be sometimes
complaining is my love language when
it's like necessary but if you're
complaining and bringing the whole team
down that's not allowed I tried not to
do that but I see how it could it
happens to me sometimes like on nights
out I'm like I really want to go home
yeah yeah I could I could always sense
when you're in one of those moods it
does ruin the night yeah I'm sorry no
but you're usually in one of those moods
yeah but that's because we are the life
of the party so like if we bow out it
ruins the night for everyone but if you
know no offense if like a lesser player
bows out just like bye go home yeah
anyway 100 so like that's just kind of
the burden we both face being these sort
of enigma creatures wow enigmatic
creatures that's the name of this
episode 100 what's new with you Claudia
oh are you does anybody ever ask you
that oh my God it's always
how are you not how am I yeah how am I
well you know I hate to bring this up oh
I know what you're gonna say but I am on
my period I also have something to talk
about here as well and I'm wearing white
pants which is so crazy I always wear
white pants on my period I don't know
why I think it makes me more cautious no
I mean like what we're not getting our
periods in the summer like we are so we
we do what we have to do
um when I posted on my story the other
day I stole Jackie's Road PR and I wrote
like stole this from Jackie um at Road
please put me on your PR list everyone
was having me like manifesting at
Claudia like whatever but no I wasn't
manifesting I was straight up asking
that's the point when I when I made that
point on the episode I was just saying
people are like misusing language these
days no that would be like that would be
like me being like stole Jackie's PR
manifesting that I get put on Rhodes PR
list one day like no I literally wrote
Road please put me on your list right
and by the way you know what I reached
out last night yes so that is what we
that's accomplishing a goal by putting
in the work it's not manifesting you
worked for it yeah I asked that was like
the point I was trying to make on the
podcast it was just like went over
everyone ads
um but how am I back to me
I'm okay
just okay just okay and you can really
only be so okay when you're on your
period if I'm being honest I mean and
day two I'm not like a day four okay you
know day two is worse than day one
I agree it is like because I thought
your body really has figured out the
fact that you have your period and like
now that Jackie's down here I feel like
I could talk we can talk about periods
like it's really easy I can talk about
my period all really yeah oh man I'm a
period talker yeah cause like life is
either just like waiting to get your
period being on your period or just
having finished and it's not just that
it's all the symptoms that come with it
I'm like oh my God why am I [__]
ravenous disturbing nothing will help
why am I yelling at everybody why do I
want to cry every five seconds and then
it's like okay whatever you get it and
you're like ah then you have to go
through the week mine is mine are long
yeah you have to go through the week of
like dealing with it right and then
afterwards you're pretty much fine and
then you start ovulating and you're like
even worse yeah even worse no but also
like once it's over
it's like you just survived it so you
have to like talk about it oh I was just
on my period like yeah it's lit I don't
know how people are not talking about
their periods every day of everyone I
just think it's so crazy like what we
deal with like on a monthly basis and
like it just it's just normal no no and
then we also have to carry the kids it's
you know
so unfair it's imbalanced it's
imbalanced and like I get definitely
resentful when I'm on my period I'm like
it should be you Ben yeah or we switch
off right right right you should have
Bend you liking around the bachelor they
do those dates of like feeling what it's
like to like be pregnant oh yeah she
left her a patreon that'd be hilarious
that would be hilarious I wonder where
you get that done you figured out have
you ever had a lie detector test done no
I kind of want to take one I would love
to take one because I like feel like I
could I could trick yeah my body I'm
like I really do believe that yes yeah
you know
you should do it I know maybe that's a
good patreon that is a good patreon
we've got a fabulous show today we've
got some stories and I'm not gonna lie
there are they like the best stories
ever I feel like news has been like
light that's what Jackie and I were
saying yesterday yesterday's episode was
called The Fast Five flop era right
because it's summertime you know
celebrities are off gallivanting they're
not really making news they're in Europe
the summer is always the worst stories
and like a holiday season they also go
off so there's not a lot going on
there's some things going on but not a
crazy amount today I'm not gonna lie to
you Margo I would never lie to you no I
didn't also like Taylor's being quiet I
do have a little bit of Taylor news some
Fallout from something that recently
happened but she's been quiet as well
it's also interesting how like you know
certain shows of hers are more
newsworthy than others like this yes the
last couple of shows were in Chicago
right and then Detroit Detroit and there
weren't like a crazy amount of celebs
and I feel like there wasn't as much
like news coming out of it coming off of
like New York shows where she did the
karma thing like I just feel like some
shows are more Buzzy than others yeah
for sure and also that's normal like
there's literally so many shows like how
much could we say yeah but I think when
she gets to La like I think the next
couple of weeks will be like not quiet
but not crazy like with Seattle unless
she's like popping out long live I had a
dream last night that she did that I
went to Jonas Brothers concert and they
sang Long Live they did yeah and I was
like okay like I got long live but like
just like not with Taylor which Jonas
sister are you like which brother do you
want to know girly you're a joker I'm a
joke early for sure yeah I mean I've
always been a joke earlier I know
definitely entering my Kevin era I feel
like I probably was a Nick early like I
was basic when I was young do you think
Nick girls are basic like kind of I do
not like I just feel like everyone
everyone was a Nick early and then like
if you were a joke early like you were
different yeah pick me yeah and then
Kevin at the time I feel like nobody
really saw and now I feel like Kevin no
now that we're all grown and we're
looking like who would be actually one
in a husband oh Kevin in a father Kevin
oh my God he's so cute with his kids
thank you Kevin that's enough thank you
Kevin that's enough passes to Kevin
Kevin Kevin's on here Kevin's on here
yeah
no nothing you just distracted me so I
lost my train of thought okay well
should we dive in we should dive in I
think we should dive in like Taylor it
would literally well you guys hear the
past five stories that you need to know
today's episode is brought to you by
Mattress Firm summer is here and
Mattress firm's July 4th sale is the
place to find high quality mattresses at
every price point this is the sale
you've been waiting for to upgrade your
sleep shop in store or online at
mattressfirm.com whether you're having
sleep trouble because of your mattress
or it's just not feeling right it is
always a good idea to get a new mattress
and Mattress Firm is the best in the biz
and they have been for many years my
mattress is for Mattress Firm I've had
it for a very long time it has aged
really well it's perfect it's not lumpy
it gives me the right amount of support
me and Ben both really like it even
though we're different types of sleepers
Mattress Firm carries high quality
mattresses for every price pan price
point from top brands like Tempur-Pedic
Stearns and Foster purple nectar
sleepies Serta and more they carry
convenient mattresses in a box if that's
what you're looking for and they also
have more than just mattresses they have
bedding and accessories for your sleep
needs so adjustable bases are a way to
relieve pain help with snoring makes
watching TV and scrolling on your phone
in bed easier with their low price
guarantee you can be confident that
you'll find the perfect match at the
best price there's really never been a
better time to get a new mattress when I
got my mattress for Mattress Firm I did
shop one of their sales it's a great
time to save money you get a great deal
with July 4th coming up
you could spend your whole summer
sleeping like a baby and I can't imagine
a better way to spend a summer honestly
so Summer's here don't forget the July
4th tale at Mattress Firm is a place to
find high quality mattresses at every
price point it's the sale you've been
waiting to upgrade at your sleep shop in
store or online at mattressfirm.com
today's episode is also brought to you
by Caraway get a head start on spring
cleaning with Caraway their thoughtfully
designed sets and complimentary storage
make getting and staying organized
easier than ever you can now save 10 off
on the full Suite of Caraway products
from their internet famous cookware to
their newly launched food storage sets
Jackie and I always talk about Caraway
you guys know if you haven't listened to
us at this point like what are you doing
would you like to make a nice summer
gazpacho I'd make a chili in the summer
I'm not above it and I'm going to be
using Caraway All Summer Long their pans
are the best if you live with someone
like Ben who loves to leave like a pan
out for hours after he's made eggs or
something you have spent many many
afternoons scrubbing pans but with that
non-stick ceramic coated surface Carrie
makes it easy to scrub your husband's
pans and they're saving marriages all
over the country and I think that's
beautiful so the naturally slick surface
means minimal oil or butter are required
for slide off the pan eggs and easy
cleaning their kitchenware comes in a
variety of very cool and Chic Shades all
the sets include complementary easy
access storage solutions you know if you
live in an apartment like I do with not
a ton of storage you have to be really
mindful about what you're bringing into
your home and Caraway is perfect I love
the way they all stack neatly I love
their food storage solutions no more
like misplacing lids and just like a
draw full of crap you know so it's
non-toxic their products are made
without any toxic materials like pfas
PTFE pfoa or other hard to pronounce
chemicals visit carawayhome.com toast10
to take advantage of this limited time
offer for 10 off your next purchase the
steel is exclusive for toast listeners
so visit carawayhome.com toast10 or use
code toast10
toast10 at checkout Caraway non-toxic
cookware made Modern
now our first story is a update from
Taylor and Maddie Healy when they were
spotted out at Casa Cipriani Taylor
Swift has now canceled her membership at
the Swanky New York City Club after
pictures of her date leaked so a source
kills page takes a Taylor Swift has
pulled her membership from the New York
City Swanky members only club Casa
Cipriani after some guests posted photos
of her on a date with Matt Healy last
month the club has a no photo policy and
they bounced the offending members for
snapping the photos of Taylor and the
1975 rocker when reached for comment the
club though denied that Swift bailed on
being a member so paid chicks reported
that at least three members got kicked
out for taking pictures of Taylor and
then that same Source added that Taylor
came knowing the policy and then had to
leave because they the photos were taken
of her but they are now cracking down
like crazy the private club let everyone
know um that two memberships were
permanently banned and then a third was
put on suspension and has to reapply for
the membership which means
um but I think it's interesting that
page six is just reporting that she
pulled her membership but
here's the thing I have a really hard
time and even like with any major celeb
I don't think that they are having
memberships to these places so what I
was going to say is like I feel like
both parties are telling the truth like
yeah yeah like I don't think Taylor
canceled her membership but I don't
think she ever had a membership I don't
think when you're at that level of
celebrity you need memberships to the
clubs they're more than happy to have
you come and like be photographed
outside yes exactly so I don't like
there's no way she's like paying monthly
members right like it's like what like a
couple thousand dollars a year there's
no way that she needs that no and I
think they need it way more I think she
will never return for sure but I don't
think she had like a full membership
that she then pulled revoked you know I
never really thought about it but I do
find it so interesting how like photos
like Leach so quickly from that and like
when she goes like zero Bond like never
not not a morsel So what had happened
was I think the photo that really took
the Internet by storm was there was a
dad there who took a picture to his
daughter and sent a picture to his
daughter that's fine which is fine like
no one would ever know about it but then
the daughter literally tweeted my dad or
like my uncle or whatever and literally
exposed who it was if it had like
surfaced on like a fan page they might
not have been able to track down who it
was but the girl I guess got so excited
and didn't really think about you know
what it would cost the person who sent
her that photo and which was like oh my
God my dad's a costume and literally
named him
that's just so dumb I know I'm sure he's
pissed yeah for sure because he probably
goes there like for business yeah stuff
no and like that's a really hard
membership club to get into yeah so once
you're in it's like oh phew but and then
it's like what if you apply to like
other like membership places like are
you now deemed as the photo taker right
there might be like a stain on your
record like you have um a red flat
whatever it's called a stain on your
permanent record yeah yeah yeah yeah
like a suspension or an expulsion from
no it's like you're on um like the
no-fly list of membership clubs did you
uh watch never have I ever The Mindy
Kaling Netflix show no you would love it
really yeah me and Ben just watch the
fourth and final season it was so cute
there's four seasons yeah and it's it's
like all through high school and I like
that they ended it at senior year and
like don't pretend they go we're going
to college we'll do long distance
honestly it sounds like a show I would
watch yeah and it's just like very well
written Mindy Kaling does such a good
job of like writing about teenagers not
in like a cringe way she like gets the
culture she does sex lives of college
girls
everything good in this world is a Mindy
Kaling thing I mean I didn't know that I
still haven't watched second season save
it it's so good yeah
so that's the difference it's a little
different it's like less sexy obviously
college girls are a little bit more also
like it would be incredibly weird I feel
like if it was like sexy high school I
guess that's Euphoria but like that's a
whole lot it's like they talk about like
losing your virginity right but not in
like a gross way yeah um which is
actually an amazing segue to a story
that I'm gonna move up now to the Second
Story oh okay great have you been
hearing about the idol
yes have you watched no I like refuse to
support too also because Shane like
posted a quote that was in it okay so
that's what the story is okay so viewers
of the new HBO Max show the idol are
horrified by the weekend's dialogue
during a sex scene with Lily Rose Depp
the premise of the show is Lily Rose
Depp plays this like pop star who gets
involved in like a cult and it's all
very like dark Hollywood which I think
conceptually doesn't sound like a bad
show but it's from the creator of
euphoria who we know is like a [__]
weird guy and it gets brushed over a lot
like what goes on in Euphoria because
the show is very good and it's like yeah
there's weird elements that are like
kind of inappropriate and bizarre but
like the show overall is good so like we
take it yeah but people are um not
loving the idol and so the weirdness is
just the only thing kind of shining
through right right and there's only
been two episodes and there's still like
all this conversation being had and what
everyone's talking about is this sex
scene
um so a nasty sex scene from the idol is
changing the way that people perceive
the weekend the Canadian singer whose
real name is Abel
um co-created the HBO series along
euphoria's Creator Sam Levinson he also
appears in the series he plays a
character named Tedros Tedros who's an
enigmatic enigmatic by the way that's
weird yeah do you think maybe I like
read I like skimmed this story before we
start started and you think maybe it was
like in my brain I didn't consciously
read it I think so because I don't
really know that enigmatic is in your
vocabulary vocabulary well I do when I
think about like enigmatic I think of
Erica Jane I'm an enigma wrapped in a
riddle I think of enigma by Lady Gaga
also a great reference okay so Tetris
Tedros is an enigmatic club owner and
cult leader who worms his way into the
life of a troubled pop star Jocelyn
who's played by Lily Rose dapp however
the show has already attracted
controversy most notably over
accusations that it depicts an
exploitive and misogynistic attitude
towards women one particular scene in
episode two which was broadcast on HBO
on Sunday
has left viewers cringing in
embarrassment it shows a fully clothed
Tedros the weekend ordering a naked and
blindfolded Jocelyn to fulfill his
sexual fantasies as he oogles her ogles
her from afar oh thank you uh at once
that's what happens because I just read
those words like they're usually in
books yeah yeah and I never know how to
pronounce it at one point he says okay
I'm not gonna repeat this so you have to
say it effing stretch that tiny little p
word
oh that wasn't even the bad one that I
saw what did you say let me pull up his
story
um and people were like quaking from
this people took to social media saying
I will never see the weekend the same
after this he definitely gives me the
Eck after this episode that scene is
straight up nasty very off-putting a
very hard watch and then more people
have criticized just the singer's acting
skills what did you read also his face
um he said imagine my tongue on your pee
my fat tongue just like
um
it's just like some things don't need to
be written no and what's so funny I
guess is like no you know what no no
I
some things because what I was saying is
like this is really dark but like I
think for a lot of people who read smut
I was just thinking that like sometimes
there's like seeing this is like just
gross way of saying it but like in smut
they say really dirty things yeah but
it's but I did reading it is so
different than like seeing somebody
verbally say it which is why those books
are so popular because it's very much a
fantasy in real life those things are
cringe yes a thousand percent I think
that when you like connect someone's
voice
to these things it automatically makes
it weird yeah but like okay so many
things one I didn't know that the
weekend was an actor or trying to be an
actor well I think this is like his
foray into it okay
being like a co-creator and an actor are
you gonna watch no no me neither at
first I'm not gonna lie like I was
curious people were saying the show was
freaky and weird and like you know there
were a lot of rumors before I came out
that it was like a very toxic set
environment and like the girls weren't
being protected and it was very sexually
explicit and they weren't following all
the guidelines like when you do have sex
in a show there has to be like an
intimacy coordinator like there's all
the Stag there are all these rules and
apparently Euphoria not you for it well
I'm sure but apparently the idol like
wasn't fully following and like a lot of
people spoke out to I think it was like
a rolling stone expose but people you
know they continued on no nothing
happened and now it's out and people
were like well I don't know what was
going on behind the scenes but on the
scenes it's [__] weird [__] weird
and
it's just giving the egg I know and also
like I love Lily Rose Depp and I wish
she wasn't part of it
I don't really have any sort of
Affliction towards Lily Rose dab I've
never seen her in anything I think she's
like stunningly beautiful you know when
she's like literally the definition of
nepo baby and like I'm living for it
like for sure like tell me somebody who
gets an HBO show starring role who I I
I'm sure she's been in stuff I've never
seen her in anything oh my God real I
feel like what is she in no I don't know
that I've seen her in anything but I
feel like she's like been acting her
whole life or what has she been modeling
perhaps modeling yeah because I feel
like she's been around yeah who's Lily
Rose Depp's mother I've known not Kate
Moss right that's someone else Lily Rose
that's her sister oh they're sisters
Lily Rose step
father oh no parents yeah I get like the
whole debt mosque people confused
her parents
are oh yeah Johnny Depp and Vanessa
Paradise who's like the woman Johnny was
married to for a really long time and
then did he marry Kate Moss he did I
don't know if they Kate Moss Johnny Depp
I do believe they were in like a
relationship or like a marriage
um
let me just clear all this up and then
who is um Kate Moss's daughter they
dated for three years they were never
married okay but then is it came out his
daughter or her sister I can never
remember Lottie Lottie I think is her
daughter no I think it's her sister
sister Lottie but can't yeah but Kate
has assist has a daughter named
something else with an L yeah Lila
that's why I was confused okay okay but
those girlies are not in relation to
Johnny Depp no not at all but no Lily
Rose Depp is like the perfect looking
specimen she's you know royalty in
Hollywood and that's how you just roll
onto an HBO show but I don't know if
anyone was expecting it to be as kind of
controversial as it is yeah and they're
just like a lot of they're awesome you
just feel like they just don't care
there's also very very very very very
very few people in this world who could
pull off saying something like gross
like that and not making it cringe and I
think the weekend who is not a
professional actor might have just
flopped which is okay Viola Davis said
it we know not everything you gotta flop
every once in a while for sure it's a
part of because we don't stop then when
you what's opposite a flop oh my God
that's so funny that you said that
literally yesterday Jackie was trying to
say something and she was like what's
the opposite of flop yeah we don't know
somebody suggest flip no maybe like like
Thrive yeah whatever you can't Thrive
without flopping because then you don't
know that you're thriving that's exactly
what Viola Davis said when she kind of
got dragged for her portrayal of
Michelle Obama in that Showtime show it
was just oh yeah it was it wasn't like
the best acting performance and she was
like you know what like you gotta flop
yeah and I was like yes I loved the
acknowledgment I mean she did it on
purpose being in your flop era so that
you can be in your Thrive era for sure
but I'm so afraid to beat my flop era of
course what's more terrifying than that
yeah I'm just gonna like I just feel
like my flop era I went through it
already yeah yeah I definitely went
through my flop hour when I had my mole
yeah you know what was your flop era
um you tell me oh my God no this is like
a great way to get into a fight no no
because this is like the games they play
on housewives no I know but I just feel
like you would know
I feel like your flop era
the thing is you're always perfect to me
so I you don't have a lot about flop Ira
that was a really nice easy way I really
can think of one
I can think of one but like I don't
really know if it's a flop hour I think
it's just called College
literally you know yeah I was definitely
flopping all over the place oh my God
but what was that is like I thought I
was like hot [__] and then I go back and
I look and I'm like girly Pat but that's
the thing about adolescence is like
you're always trying to find yourself
and you go through like various weird
stages thinking like oh I found myself
I'm writing my skateboard like this is
who I'm meant to be remember us on our
penny boards right like you go through
these weird phases to ultimately get to
who you are today right right and who
you are today you might look back on and
cringe isn't that scary yes but I I feel
pretty confident in who I am today I
don't know that I would look back on me
right now but you would have said that
in college too no I don't think I would
have you would have I don't think I
would say like this is who I am like I
need to work on my art leave me alone
mommy ruining my life that was you
literally
but I would have if you would have asked
me I would say like this is who I meant
to be and I will always be this person
it's just what I'm saying counts
are you ready for some some news I am
also there is something I want to
discuss but I don't know if it's a Fast
Five what is it summer I turn pretty
let's talk about it the trailer the
trailer the kind of Orchestral Version
of August by Taylor Swift they're always
putting Taylor Swift in their soundtrack
last season for the
trailer I think it was this love right
was it this love is good this love and
then the actual soundtrack had lover
Cruel Summer the way I loved you oh oh
the way I loved you that scene I read
those books maybe three years ago and I
felt like a little too old to be reading
it but it was kind of like a guilty
pleasure like teeny bopper young adult
romance and it was really sweet and now
I'm three years older and the way I'm so
invested and like obsessed with the show
I read the books five years ago when I
was in college and I that's a perfect
time to read them yeah but even then I
felt too old yeah
um and I thought they were good I wasn't
like dead like dying for it and then the
show came out and I was like oh my God
so good and then I reread all of the
books just because I wanted to know what
happened what happened even though I
feel like I don't know that they're
completely gonna like I think they will
no I think they will in terms of like
like who she ends up with but in terms
of like how to get there I don't know
that it'll be the same yeah
um but no the way that I'm like just
like a obsessed no same like just Jenny
hand does such a good job at like
like bringing her work to life yes but
also like
she just like has her like finger on the
pulse in terms of like just like getting
Taylor involved and like I mean I don't
know if that was her no but like I don't
know if it was her but I definitely
she's a huge Swifty yeah and so it was a
little less so I'm sure that whoever the
person is that's in charge of getting
sound rights yeah she was like you need
to get Taylor to approve and then when
everyone was dying that Taylor was part
of it I'm sure Taylor then leaned out
yeah it's literally the best show it's
so beautifully done like where his
cousins I'm going no I know that house
was stunning I'm so I can't believe
there are people who are not team Conrad
like it's disgusting I'm so it makes
like no sense no Jeremiah he's not
trying to be a joke early
it's like pick me energy like Jeremiah
is not it he will never be it he never
was it like it's so clear he's just like
borderline annoying yeah he's like
immature on the show like Conrad yeah
he's like Moody and stuff because he's
like going through he's finding himself
and he needs he needs
belly belly that's kind of like the only
problem I have with the book belly like
like don't call a girl belly like it's
not nice
so mean it's so it's not nice thank God
she doesn't be like body image issues
because if she did and everyone was
running around you know belly the beach
calling her belly yeah that would be
destructive I couldn't agree toward her
mental health and self-confidence a
thousand percent attitude July 14th I
can't wait I literally remember I was at
a wedding like a destination wedding in
Montreal the last time it came out and
my TV had Netflix and I almost cried I
watched the entire thing the wedding
weekend like I couldn't wait till I got
home no I'm watching it the night it
comes out I'm but also I kind of want to
re-watch the first one like let's relive
it again yeah I rewatched it twice but I
would rewatch it again it is Far and
Away the best show and I know it's like
I'm too old for it but what I like about
it is that it doesn't make me feel weird
no it's also like a sort of like
Nostalgia that's what it is so it's like
we're not watching it being like oh
we're in the same position as these
people right like it brings you back to
when you were that age it like glorifies
that time in your life when like you're
getting older and like you start liking
like having like real relationships and
you think it's like the great love of
your life right it's right Nostalgia is
the perfect word oh I can't wait I'm
actually gonna like literally run home
and watch the first season again okay
but the story I was gonna get into which
was not that is Aaron Rodgers is
confusing people
because he attended the 2023 Tony Awards
and everyone on the internet was beyond
confused he's been doing weird things
lately he caused quite the reaction on
social media after his surprising
attendance to the 76th annual award show
celebrating Broadway stars on Sunday
night he arrived with his uh New York
Jets teammate CJ uzoma so he was sleekly
dressed he looked great but everyone was
like why are you here [__] I have a
theory well we we do find out why but I
would have thought
um yeah it's weird but he's like a New
Yorker that's what I'm saying and he's
the star of he's going to bring this
franchise back to life right when you
become like the star of a New York team
New York teams aren't great so like when
they have a star player Carmelo Anthony
like you become like the most famous
person in New York you're on the cover
of the New York Post every day like yeah
that's just par for the course so going
to what's more what's more of a New York
event than the Tonys no for sure I feel
like he's like they're in their off
season now so he is like I need to be
the boy about town in New York like
go to all the hot spots go to all the
hot things Taylor Swift like just like
so I like he's doing his part which is
isn't this what we would want him to be
doing as the face of New York so people
like trick to social media and we're
like the way Aaron Rodgers looks at the
Tonys is the exact way I picture him
looking at the tones
um Aaron Rodgers looks like he just
spotted a member of his family at the
Tonys are my eyes messed up or is that
Aaron Rodgers at the Tonys Aaron Rodgers
at the Tonys is like Nathan Lane at the
ESPYs so
um it didn't it then did come out that
the teammate he arrived with whose name
was CJ
I'm sorry I'm literally having a stroke
CJ zoma was actually a producer of one
of the shows so he was there like
supporting a teammate there was a
connection it was definitely bizarre but
like not really actually and also even
if that wasn't the case like I think
what we said I don't think it's I don't
see it as a problem no me neither it
makes a little sense do you think he met
Leah Michelle
that's a good question
did you see the picture of Lee Michelle
and Alex Noel
no her Glee co-star who won a Tony
um I think a lot of people were like
quaking that they were going to be in
the same room because when a lot of
people you know came out speaking about
Leah like I think Alex was you know
involved oh and in a bad way yeah like
not in a complimentary way and Leah
posted a photo with Alex and was like
congratulations
because Alex wanted Tony oh I saw her
whole story but I said she shouldn't put
it together
um yeah and she's also just like it's
like a Glee moment yeah I saw her post a
photo with Darren Chris but
don't we know that they're thick as
thieves yeah yeah the lmdc tour oh my
God and when they went on tour together
Lea Michele and Darren Chris and they
couldn't come up with a better name for
the tour than the LMC
so true
somewhere Rachel Barry is yes it's just
like I feel like her run is almost up
have you seen it
are you okay did you come with me yeah
oh sorry I forgot no she extended no I
know but like that was a while ago yeah
but I feel like she'll extend again even
sad that she couldn't win the Tony
because like only when you reprise the
role are you eligible
like beanie would have been eligible oh
that's what it is yeah she wasn't even
nominated she's not eligible for that
category oh it's only like the original
cast
like when the show first comes out
that's so [__] yeah
I was wondering why yeah because
obviously if she had been she would have
won one she brought Broadway back right
but she's not eligible for the
nomination at least they let her host
right she hosted
yeah she just performed I think oh I
don't think they would have let her host
like it's too much it's too much like
yeah no I don't think so oh okay
um okay so Aaron Rodgers had his reasons
just like you
today's episode is brought to you by
Lululemon specifically the Lululemon
shorts they were made to stretch flex
and support the infinite ways of working
out giving you the courage to LEAP into
something totally new and unexpected so
they have tons of fabulous shorts at
Lululemon I feel like Lululemon is a
go-to destination for so many of you
guys but with summer time it's so hot in
the studio today I wish I was wearing my
Lululemon shorts with summertime you
know kind of being here already it's so
hot you're running errands you're
working out you need comfortable shorts
that are going to absorb you know all
the moisture in your nether regions and
Lululemon is a brand that you can trust
so the hottie hot short is one of my
favorites they're a comfortable short
with a comfortable range of motion so
you can move freely with confidence
they're lightweight Swift fabric lets in
airflow so you can move without baggage
it's designed to Wick away sweat before
you even notice that it's there they
also have the Wonder train short it's a
short with supportive stretch that keeps
you dry it's powered by everlux fabric
the Wonder train collection manages heat
and sweat so you stay comfortable and
focused it's sweat wicking quick drying
and really supportive in terms of
stretch I will not put anything on my
body that does not stretch it's just not
like I'm at a point in my life where
that's just my role and everything at
Lululemon is so comfortable weightless
fabulous they also have great men's
stuff you know Father's Day coming up
for the man in your life you can get
them the pace breaker short it's a
versatile short that's up to any
challenge it has Secure Storage which
means you can keep things close without
feeling them bounce around so get into
the Lululemon shorts at lululemon.com
that's l-u-l-u lemon.com today's episode
is also brought to you by article
Summer's on its way and if you've been
dreaming up ideas for your outdoor space
and how to make the most of it well the
time is now you don't want to spend
another summer with like you know
unusable outdoor seating areas that's
why you gotta check out article you guys
the best thing about summer is getting
to do all of your favorite indoor things
outside so it means having meals
watching movies falling asleep on the
couch everything is just better Alfresco
especially under the summer Stars so
check out article they believe in
delightful design for every home and
thanks to their online only model they
have some really delightful prices too
so their curated assortment of bid
Sentry modern Coastal industrial scandi
and boho does signs make furniture
shopping simple their team of designers
are all about finding the perfect
balance between style quantity and price
they're dedicated to thoughtful
craftsmanship that stands the test of
time and looks good at doing it so
there's so many things to love about
article one their price points are
really fair they're good quality
furniture they have a ton of different
styles so whether you're going for like
a coastal grandmother aesthetic you can
find whatever you're looking for an
article but really I think the best part
of article is the shipping Jackie's out
she's like the screened-in porch area in
her house and she got a ton of furniture
from article and I was actually there
when it got delivered it was so
efficient they were so communicative it
did not take a crazy long time which a
lot of furniture companies are doing now
so it's affordable shipping across the
US and Canada they won't leave you
waiting around because you picked the
delivery time and they send you updates
every step of the way their customer
care team is super knowledgeable so when
you need them they will be there to make
sure your experience is smooth and
stress-free and they're offering our
listeners 50 off your first purchase of
100 or more which is pretty fabulous to
claim visit article.com toast and the
discount will be automatically applied
at checkout that's art circle.com
t-o-a-s-t for fifty dollars off your
first purchase of 100 or more ready for
our next story which is kind of sad well
no it's sad
Pat Sajak has announced his retirement
from Wheel of Fortune after 41 Seasons
he says the time has come on Monday the
76 year old TV personality announced
that he would retire after the show's
upcoming 41st season which begins
filming in September well the time has
come I've decided that our 41st season
which begins in September will be my
last it's been a wonderful ride and I'll
have more to say in the coming months
many thanks to you all
um he posted it on Twitter which is you
know very cool of him very relaxed Pat
Sajak's relaxed
um and now of course while this is sad
everyone's like well who is it going to
be right right well I mean you know what
it's sad it makes sense no it's it is
time it is time like you can't
do something forever but you know he's
really a staple in the homes of millions
of Americans I think a lot of people
have seen him on their TV show like you
know their grandparents have seen them
yes for sure so it begs the question who
fills the role who fills the role and I
think so you know wheel Fortune Vanna
White yes okay because people are saying
that who they're grooming Somebody's
Daughter to take over Vanna White was it
pat sajaks oh I didn't know that that's
what I saw oh that's either Vanna
White's daughter or Pat Sajak's daughter
but then what Vanna would then become
Pat no Vanna like will return yeah yeah
yeah I mean when Jeopardy when Alex
Trebek passed away like a few people
came to mind to be Replacements I think
a lot of people immediately assumed Ken
Jennings
um so there was like a few people in the
running I really can't think of anyone
Who's Gonna Fill In I feel like it'll be
like
a professional host yes
I'm thinking also because like it's a
lot of work it's a Daily Show it's it's
a lot of work they film like a million
episodes a year yeah it's a great job
it's a great job coveted job it's a job
with a lot of you know job security I
feel like they're gonna go with a young
in yeah
um not too young no no no no but like
30s 40s yeah hmm I know maybe a woman
maybe I mean maybe Vanna right is that I
don't know is that a bad call I think so
because like if that is still on the
show like she should be doing like what
she's known to be doing I think yeah
I mean uh can we talk about Havana has
like the best job in the whole world no
literally she doesn't even speak yeah I
mean look at this picture of a Vanna
White and Pat Sajak from when they first
started like they've been doing this for
40 years you know what's so crazy that
like they didn't end up together
I know but like
yeah that's actually a good point I
think when I was younger like I thought
they were married yeah of course
but they're not they're not they're
probably just really good friends or
they hate each other he began hosting
the Wheel of Fortune in 1981. that's so
crazy so crazy talk about job security
but and they won't just end the show
right no it's like a it's a staple an
American culture also I'm sure the
ratings are still good like why would
they right right
um
Vanna said like years ago in an
interview I don't even want to think
about that Pally Pat or us leaving I
mean we're a team that's depressing I
don't even want to think about it so
they've never like really said who they
what they think will happen after their
time they like just assumed it would go
on forever right
um well I am available would you do it
yeah
okay you know what I mean like you have
to move to LA no I feel like they would
do it here for me you know oh for sure
they would like no
that like you couldn't leave your family
right right but it's a dream job
honestly you literally do nothing that's
true and you're just like and you just
like are like no you don't even do it
the other all the contestants do it you
do it once at the end oh yeah for the
final spin do you have you ever even
watched before Desperate Housewives no
literally I only as a kid like yeah I
watched it but like either because it
was like on a Grammy and Pop's house
yeah or um it was like I was waiting for
my show for Desperate Housewives yeah
channel seven can you believe how young
we were watching Desperate House I'm
always talking about that um no also a
lot of things like me especially because
I had three older sisters so like I
would watch whatever you guys watch like
the OC yeah that was a dark show yeah
that was a dark show Gossip Girl boy
gospel was fun like I didn't think that
that was fine yeah but I also feel like
Gossip Girl was a little bit later I
think we were in like I was in high
school for Gossip Girls I was in Middle
High School like both like seventh
eighth nine but yeah no the OC I
remember watching like so yeah Marissa
was like always going down like dark
murder
they covered some like heavy topics gun
violence that episode yeah yeah they
covered they covered some heavy [__]
like that we might have been too young
to be watching for sure but Desperate
Housewives yeah but Desperate Housewives
was so aesthetically pleasing to watch
and I feel like that's really all I
cared about was like the Suburban like
Bree with her hair and like whatever but
then I don't really think I understood
what was going on okay wait I'm so glad
you brought that up because never have I
ever is filmed on Wisteria Lane does it
look like it yeah I mean didn't you go
to a cereal I did Davey and her mom live
in Susan Meyer's house it's like a
little different but if you know with
cereal and you know it and every now and
then they're like driving or bikes
biking like down the street and it's
Wisteria Lane across the street from
their house like sometimes you can see
when they're like standing outside their
house is Lynette's house and all the
houses like they can be taken down and
like changed a little bit but the
outside is still very much the same like
Susan says yellow Lynette's green like
and uh when I went to Wisteria Lane I
did um daily pop
on the universal lot and Justin
Sylvester like gave me a tour and I was
like we went to um where they what's the
town in um
[__] me in the ass what's the Heart of
Dixie yes uh Bluebell Bluebell which is
also I think Stars Hollow from Gilmore
Girls okay
then I was like is Wisteria Lane here it
was like oh yeah and we went and Gabby
solis's house is like I think the only
one that hasn't changed a bit we like
sat on the steps it was one of the
coolest things no that is so cool like
that just is like so iconic iconic oh so
Heart of Dixie iconic show not talked
about enough yeah I never finished it
I'm glad you should I know song Live the
heart long live the soul who knows what
he wants it need to breathe sure I have
no idea what you're talking about they
came on the show and they like performed
at one of like the town functions like
the church bake sale no like you know
they always had like their block parties
yeah
um those towns are like not real
I know they're not actually really [__]
like that doesn't happen I know and if
it does I need to go uh no I dream to
like live in a small town where like you
know nobody pays taxes and they all just
like live in nice houses and like work
like never and there's every weekend
there's like you know the the church
dance-off or the library read along like
there's always these like where is that
did you ever watch Virgin River
because it's it's literally the plot of
Heart of Dixie just like a bit more
dramatic and like older what channel
Netflix and the do you remember you know
remember the Doctor Who was always mean
to Rachel bielsen like when she came in
Nielsen yeah yeah he's the same Doctor
Who's mean to the new nurse it's the
same thing that's weird yeah
and Scott Porter is in Heart of Texas
from China street from Friday Night
Lights he's also do you watch um Jenny
and Georgia no you don't no for some
reason I can't get into the like never
have I ever Sydney and George's like oh
my God Margo you have to watch Jenny and
Georgia Olivia made me watch it she's
like it's so bad but it's so good and
that's literally the definition it's the
worst show on television okay um and
like you will hate Ginny but she's just
like a young girl going through it you
know you can't blame them you can't
blame her and it's and Scott Porter's in
it at least he like has got like a nice
career I feel like if I could want to be
anyone like in terms of level of Fame
like Scott Porter definitely lives a
very nice normal life he probably makes
a lot of money he has like an iconic
role but he's not so famous he can go to
the grocery store like maybe one person
will ask him for a cell or like he'll
walk by and never be like why does that
guy look so familiar yes giving like
Judy Greer energy yeah yeah you know
Judy Greer yeah she's also like I think
she's like a very well-known person not
really I think oh is she the one in 13
going around 30 yes okay she's like the
friend in everything I think the title
of her Memoir was um I don't know where
you know me from that's okay because
people are always like where do I know
you from
and that's her I think that's so rude
it's so rude but I think she took her
power back let me just make sure I'm not
making that up Judy Greer memoir
I feel like that's also a good book
I don't know what you know me from
confession My Life as a co-star
that's such a good name
and I feel like her book is good
I kind of want to read it
um so she's very much like giving Scott
Porter energy yeah they both have iconic
roles 13 Going on 30 but they've also
been in everything never as the star
right Taylor Kitsch can't go anywhere
Taylor Kitsch can't go anywhere Rachel
bielsen can't go anywhere no Rachel
bills why can't you say her name Bilson
Rachel Nielsen Rachel Nelson Rachel
bielson Nielsen what is it Bilson Wilson
I like bielson Nielsen I like Rachel
bielsen she's really spirited
Rachel Bilson is like a
A-list like she's like a star 100 she is
no matter what she's on the same
category no although I do wish her and
you know
Seth Cohen had worked out save but Seth
Cohen and Blair Waldorf like you
couldn't have asked for a better
crossover but like don't you think
Leighton Meester and Rachel Bilson are
the same person Cut From the Same Cloth
a thousand percent yeah he obviously has
a type yes for sure love that for him
all right are you ready for it for the
final story I am which like honestly is
a story like I genuinely I do not care
about but it was on the cover of every
single thing and I feel like maybe
people care about Ezra Miller
I don't know who that is okay so Ezra
Miller made his first public showing for
the first time in nearly nearly two
years on Monday night after attending
the LA premiere of The Flash so I
obviously had never heard of Ezra Miller
until
um
all these allegations came out about him
and there was like this video that went
around of him like choking a woman and a
lot of misconduct allegations came about
him so oh the first time I learned about
him was like oh he's done you know
that's what my first interaction was
with him oh he'll never work in this
town again okay
um but now it's like nobody cares he's
going to this big premiere of a movie I
mean he spoke openly about the
misconduct allegations levied against
them and various legal woes that he
addressed they addressed their fans and
many industry players at the Chinese
Theater in Hollywood so uh there was a
big show of acknowledging Warner
Brothers the discovery CEO
um basically thanking them for their
Grace and discernment and and Care in
the context of my life and in bringing
this moment to fruition so here's
basically what happens like a lot of
words
were like famous and then all these
things happen in the course of like a
couple of weeks
Miller was charged with felony burglary
in Vermont police investigated their
involvement in a robbery at a private
residence
in 2020 a video emerged depicting Ezra
Miller as they appeared to be choking a
woman outside a bar in Iceland no
charges were filed the actor was also
arrested twice in Hawaii so he's just a
criminal all over the world once for
disorderly conduct and harassment pled
no contest to a single count of
misdemeanor disorderly conduct in the
Hawaii case and paid a 500 fine the
harassment charge was dismissed but then
he received Rockstar welcome at the
flash Premiere introduced by director
Andy muschietti uh so yeah I just find
it interesting how I find it interesting
how the machine picks and chooses who to
cancel who to hold accountable if you're
gonna hold people accountable hold
everyone accountable if you're gonna
hold not everyone accountable don't hold
anyone accountable right because I guess
there are varying degrees but this
reminds me of like somebody who was you
know actively acting and promoting stuff
who had allegations come out Army Hammer
right they replaced his role in a movie
with Josh dumel they he was on death and
Death on the Nile was already filmed and
they did like a fake Premiere didn't
invite him like the movie was kind of
swept under the rug right um even though
it was actually a very good I was gonna
say such a good movie we watched it so
it's just interesting how like Army
Hammer would be arguably harder to like
because he's he was established at the
time to like do every household name
yeah like to like get rid like not get
rid of but let's get rid of get rid of
whereas this guy no one knows him from
Adam he's not well known easy to have
just been like oh well we tried we gave
you a shot you kind of botched it bye
yeah I feel like people at least for me
my only experience with Ezra Miller is
the bad things about him right so it's
just I always find it so interesting who
Hollywood like chooses and doesn't
choose there's such a
selective outrage yes and it's like I
guess we're not caring about Ezra Miller
okay cool noted noted I was never going
to see The Flash I don't particularly
know or care about Ezra Miller and my
life remains unaffected but I guess if
you're in the DC Marvel world like this
is big news for you oh yeah the DC
Marvel world is a whole other thing I
have not seen this is just kind of like
a crazy fact about me like I've never
seen a Marvel movie I don't know which
I've seen I think you saw Wonder Woman
which is Marvel DC I'm sorry I don't
know which one is I don't know which
one's which like I've seen Wonder Woman
I've seen the super some of the Superman
movies you have like I mean the OG ones
I remember with like Andrew Garfield I
feel like we saw Spider-Man sure oh yeah
yeah I saw uh and I saw Tobey Maguire oh
Toby McGuire I saw him and then I saw
the most recent one with Zendaya and was
it good yeah they're so cute yeah um and
then I've seen
I think I weirdly saw Black Widow once I
tried to take Magnolia to a movie and it
was just off just you and Magnolia no no
and I was with a friend that was your
flop era yeah no literally and she was
like barking the whole time because it's
so like not not actually barking like I
could hear her growl so I'd like hold
her oh my God I took Theo to lunch if
you like a week ago and He barked in the
middle of the quiet restaurant it was
one of the most horrifying things yeah I
know it's extremely frightening um and
then I saw
what else is there I don't know but I
actually kind of want to get into it I
feel like it's like a whole world oh
Batman I've seen obviously Ben made me
see Batman with uh well we saw the one
with the pizza Ledger like when we were
young I didn't see it Dark Knight Rises
one of my favorite movies no I know did
you never see my comedy special disgrace
Queen where I talk about Dark Knight
Rises and how I've never seen it
I mean I was on tour with you and I
don't remember that yeah like about how
I just used to like lie about stuff for
no reason oh yeah yeah when people be
like have you seen Dark Knight Rises and
I was like yeah yeah even though I had
it it's so good available to stream now
on Amazon Prime I want to see the new
Batman with Robert Pattinson which I
know came out like a year ago yeah me
too but I only want to see it because
Robert Pattinson and Ben is like a
Batman obsessed and he didn't love it
but I think he just feels deeply
connected to Christian Bale that's a
pleasure
yeah he was the Joker yeah why are you
no I don't know like this whole universe
I don't because like okay and then
there's the Joker movies yeah with
Joaquin Phoenix
is that DC Marvel
I'm I'm gonna assume it because those
feel like more elevated art films maybe
right no but honestly like dark knight
rises even feels like more elevated art
films too then like
The Avengers
yeah Avenger end game yeah Wanna Be Your
end game and also I know how Avengers
end game ends like somebody told me oh
don't tell me also did you have any fomo
for men cheering this weekend no
I didn't think I would but I saw like
everybody there Margo except he wasn't
when I asked when someone told me I was
like how was it and they were like so
good like amazing I was like was it a
one-man show and they were like yeah we
went to win a chair in a concert and
like I'm sorry it was just not a good
concert like I'm not into the whole
intimate setting at a stadium like I
need you to have a band no it's like if
it's just you your guitar and your Loop
like that's cool for maybe in a couple
of songs yeah yeah but like if I can
hear the planes flying above the stadium
louder than I can hear you what's what
are we doing here I understand like
museums are stadiums we saw life goes on
with Luke and Edge here and like I'm
good that song that collab that Ed
Sheeran did with Luke Combs I feel like
nobody's talking about it it's I will
listen to it every day
and like that little run like Luke jumps
Luke does is so
yeah so I was telling everyone this like
my summer of concerts even though like I
missed a concert last week but I just
wasn't in the mood no a con how was it
can we talk about that yeah I mean it
was amazing like now it looks like he
sounds so much better live than he does
on like he sounds the same but like with
like the band he just it sounded so good
that now when I listen to the music it's
not enough yeah like I need like to hear
like that's what they say like I don't
headphones isn't enough I need this song
up my ass yeah I need his songs up my
ass yeah he was so so good also like so
proudly Jewish like I love love that I
always forgot that about him yeah like
they were calling like Jewish Capaldi
um and he was just like amazing and he
put on such a good show and like
everybody there knew everything go [__]
and everyone there like knew how special
it was because it was very hard to get
tickets impossible
um but knows like it was just so good
and Have you listened to his new songs
like the one that on the top yeah
[Music]
um no it was so good okay good he'll be
here we're going to Luke
um yes in Boston if you ever actually
talk to me you know Margaret like we
need to plan this trip to Boston but
like I'll play Nothing is planned and
I'm just like we need to just like take
20 minutes I know and figure it out I
hate planning stuff Margaret would like
text me I'm such a planner Margo will
text me like once a week are you in a
good headspace to plan our Boston
weekend nah I'm such a planner because
like I just like I need I just need to
know what I'm doing like I plan my weeks
out I know what I'm doing like whatever
so like I just it's easier to get it
done no for sure for sure we'll plan it
soon I promise
um
and I think we might also go to Philly
like if if we feel like it yeah and what
other concerts are going on this weekend
I mean this summer we should go to I
don't know I got another country
Festival oh Festival I know I feel like
there's so many over the summer or I
feel I don't know if
I don't know if they're like during true
summer like I know there was like
Tortuga and there's like a bunch of
random ones I feel like in like May
but I don't know I would totally go to a
festival but I don't know what there is
and then also
um
we should go to Taylor again yeah we're
thinking about
um about going to jail again that's
pretty I just feel like I'm not
satisfied even though I went three times
I actually do feel satisfied I don't
feel satisfied but I want to go again
you know agreed is real I'm committing
the sin of greed yes me as well um
honestly you know what I'm gonna do some
research like who's playing at um PNC
Jones Beach yeah like all those outdoor
amphitheaters it should be the summer of
concerts for sure that's a really good
point I'll look into that the only thing
is it's like it's just so annoying it's
like Rascal Flatts like it's no longer
together no I know but Gary is on tour
and he does sing Rascal Flatts No it's
not the same of course yeah but I'm
gonna I'm gonna look at it okay thanks
counts you're welcome not to give you
like jobs or anything it's fine then I'm
gonna look it in and like do all the
planning and then I'm just gonna need
her to be like yes or no and she's not
gonna answer me for two weeks yeah no I
won't
um all right that's our show you guys
tomorrow we are audio only with Jax and
that'll be available Audio Only so
counts thank you so much for giving up
your early morning for us we deeply
appreciate you and your cool Lots thank
you I definitely appreciate appreciate
it thank you lots code Marco xbang thank
you guys so much for listening to the
testimony Morning Show we deliver the
past five stories you need to know
everybody on YouTube please subscribe
uh
yeah like just make it make it the best
day to you know grind hustle like make
the best day of your life now you know
don't forget to like you know hustle all
day bro and like you know eat some meat
love you bye